[Music]
here we are talking to dean blandino fox
nfl and college football rules analyst
kind enough to join us all right dean um
what do you take away from that play
yeah it's certainly look this has been a
point of emphasis we've been talking
about taunting i always try to put
myself in my old role okay put yourself
in the in the position of the official
and and from where tony currently
standing he sees marsh kind of walk
toward the bench
maybe he thinks he's talking to harvin
the punter and and it looks to him
like taunting it's been this point of
emphasis and he's going gonna throw his
flag then you get the the hip check
which i have a hard time
explaining that
um i just think we've gone too far with
this you know tony mentioned in his in
his pool report that he was posturing
look
to me
it looked like marsh maybe maybe he
might have said something i mean he's
he's 30 yards away this isn't right at
the bench area where he's drawing
getting up in somebody's face i'd love
to see more of him in somebody's face
especially in that situation where
you're basically it's a first down for
the steelers that that's a tough one and
then you get the the contact at the end
which is which is really difficult to
explain
do you think that the official tried to
make contact with cassius marsh i you
know if if you sit here and ask me do i
think he intentionally i would say no i
would say absolutely under no
circumstance is he trying to make make
contact with marsh
but you watch the video and it certainly
looks like that way i'm not in tony's
head i don't know i would i'd be shocked
if that were the case uh but you watch
the video and i'm not gonna sit here and
say
some people won't think that i i don't
think that's the case but it's tough
with the video the way it the way it
looked i just didn't understand the
timing of it dean because if he did
taunt okay there was ample time to throw
the flag for taunting
the flag didn't really come out and go
into the air until they made contact
with each other
yeah and and tony was very clear that
the contact had nothing to do with the
flag and
you know but if anything it was tony
maybe he lost his balance i don't know
it just didn't look good but again he's
processing it he's giving maybe he's
giving marsh the opportunity okay is he
gonna keep walking toward the bench area
i'm gonna give him a chance to walk away
you know let it play out it is a big
situation in the game and and i guess he
felt that it crossed the line and now
he's going to throw the flag and then
you get the contact it just
it's just not a great it's just not a
good deal when we're sitting here
talking about something like that when
we should be talking about like you said
the steelers you know trying to put the
bears away the bears with it with a
great comeback
and we end up having an exciting finish
because you know what would have
happened if it was reverse dean
oh ejection disqualification out of the
game no question yeah i i know that
they're calling this and there's an
emphasis for this but what was the
ground swell that said we've got to call
these we've got to really emphasize the
taunting here
yeah and this is this has happened
before at my time at the nfl this came
from the coaches subcommittee which is a
committee that works with the
competition committee it's made up of
head coaches you know andy reid is the
is the chair there's coaches like ryan
flores and mike grebel who's now verbal
is going to move to the competition
committee next year
and they had had voiced some concern
about the sportsmanship and a any kind
of a lack of sportsmanship and more of
the in your face taunting type stuff
that wasn't getting called and so i can
understand that if you feel like there's
actions that are not being called that
are fouls by by definition in the rule
book and we want to clean that up that's
great and and that's important and we
want to make sure right it's player
safety number one sportsmanship number
two and then competitive equity number
three
but
it feels like we've almost gone to a new
standard for taunting that that that now
it's not it's it's not so much cleaning
up what we thought we were missing now
it's like anything anything that could
be directed at an opponent posturing
we're getting flags and the flags are up
significantly it's not it's not like we
have four or five flags a game it's
still less than one a game but it just
feels like the standard has changed and
i'm not sure
if the competition committee is
comfortable with that great then then
they're not going to have to make any
adjustments but i'm not sure if they're
going to be comfortable at the end of
the year when they look at the whole
picture yeah i don't want to put more on
the officials plates i don't want them
to adjudicate you know i gotta read into
what is intent here i mean it's it's
it's already tough it's the toughest
sport to officiate and now we've added
intent and i i just think i'm worried
that we're gonna get to a playoff game
dean
like this is a standalone regular season
game that's why we're talking about it
if this is a wild card game and you had
a play like this a moment like this
you know that's how rules get changed
but this is you know then there's a big
deal uh with you know implications money
on it from gambling you know there's
just
they
i don't know i think they need to
de-emphasize taunting the officials get
together here halfway point of the
regular season
let's let's hit a reset button here like
we've done with holding before or past
interference before where we maybe you
know we slow it we slow it down a little
bit
that's certainly possible and then the
competition competition committee has
done that before like you mentioned
withholding we've seen that in previous
years
and and to get to give the officials i
think the officials have been really
good over the years and understanding
what is taunting and what is just the
normal emotion the normal the normal
kind of back and forth that happens
during the game they've been really good
at that and this feels like you said
we've given them another thing on their
plate and now look they're being told on
training tapes every week these taunting
plays are highlighted these are calls we
need to get and they're and it's
hammered in so if you have that somebody
telling you hey you got to get these
taunting calls you're going to go out
and you're going to look for that stuff
and that's what i feel like is happening
to some extent i feel like the officials
are really good when you give them some
discretion say hey get the big ones get
the ones that's in your face the obvious
unsportsmanlike stuff and the other
stuff the emotional stuff um let's let
the game keep you know let that continue
in the game let's not have 15 yard
penalties impact games we're talking to
dean blandino fox nfl and college
football rules analyst but you can see
the steelers defense
run 60 yards together collectively down
to the end zone slide into the end zone
and take a snapshot
i can watch lamar jackson do a cartwheel
into the end zone or a somersault
that's not taunting
i know and this is and this has been i
remember talking to coaches bill
belichick and he had the same things
that we're letting everybody run into
the end zone doing these celebrations
and then we're gonna ask the the players
on the other side to kind of temper
their emotions and it's it's kind of you
can't have it both ways and again the
emotion is good you don't the league is
so cognizant of not they do not like
there are people in at 3 45 park that do
not like when they are called the no fun
league they don't like it and so they're
trying to allow the celebrations allow
some of that emotion and now you turn
around and you get a play like this or
an emphasis like this that seems to be
trying to to to keep the emotions in
check it's tough it's tough when you
tell players one thing in one area and
then in another area hey you got to turn
around and just walk away don't do
anything that's going to give the
official an opportunity to throw the
flag how often do officials get together
at halftime and maybe
stress over emphasize or de-emphasize
something that's happened in the game oh
yeah halftime is for the officials is no
different than than the players the
coaches right you make halftime
adjustments as a coach you know with the
players officials will do that they'll
talk about how what's the tenor of the
first half right is the game getting out
of control you know is the game under
control are we doing you know nothing
really we have to adjust
so so they'll have that conversation at
half time not that we're gonna we're
gonna change how we officiate the game
and the standard right that should be
consistent but certainly if certain
things have happened in the first half
that we need to be careful about we need
to adjust to they're going to have that
conversation during half time and uh you
know so they can go out in the second
half and make sure that everything stays
you know stays under control
nfl do anything today
i i don't know you know for me i again i
think about myself in the same in my old
spot and i would have had a long
conversation with tony cronin last night
about that game and that's never good
and and so they're going to review
everything they're going to go through
it i don't know
what you know what's going to come out
of that i don't know if there's any
further discipline or anything else from
the game but if you were in your old
spot dean and you're having a
conversation with tony corenti after
last night's game what would you want to
know
i i want to know hey and this and i know
i've known tony carney a long time and
he's a great man he's been a great
official for a long time i go tony what
the heck happened on that tawny why what
did what why did you bump the player
what happened talk to me tell me what
happened i want to hear his perspective
right because i don't think he did it
intentionally but what happened what was
going through your mind what was the
thought process you know why did you
throw the flag how did that all play out
let's talk about the the low block that
you called earlier in the game let's
talk about any other issues you know any
issues with the coaches we're just going
to go through it because i wouldn't want
to make any decisions on anything
before talking to him talking to the
crew and getting their perspective
because this is a hard right it's a hard
job like you said it's it's this is one
of the toughest professions in in in not
just sports and and the evaluation the
the scrutiny that they're under it's so
intense
and uh and look sometimes we mess it up
sometimes we screwed up i screwed up
when i was at the league office um but
there's a lot of riding on these games
and you want to have you want to make
sure that that those you know you limit
those those times when there are when
there are mess-ups
ever having a head coach call you to
complain about an official
yeah a long time i had a head coach
call me on monday to complain about an
official and i'm no longer at the league
office so
it's uh it happens all the time and and
look they're coaches head coaches
understand for the most part they
understand officials are going to make
mistakes right they know coaches make
mistakes players make mistakes officials
make mistakes what they don't tolerate
what they don't want is when it's poor
communication right if i can't get if
i'm on the sideline i can't get an
answer from an official or referee about
something if the communication is terse
or it's it's it's disrespectful or
anything like that that's when coaches
have a problem and and that's when it
becomes about one official it's not this
official miss to hold that's gonna
happen it's this official isn't
communicating with me this official
didn't didn't give me the opportunity to
uh you know understand what was going on
and that happens quite a bit when
coaches have that you know have that
conversation do you think ed hoculey
will get enough credit for his arms and
how jack they were and the fact that he
had you know his his outfit
enhanced that i mean he's the godfather
of the uh party pump before it came he
he is and that and i hope that's not
ed's legacy because i think as we talk
about communication ed was excellent at
communicating there were referees over
the years johnny grier gene steritor
comes to mind ed hockley that
communicated with coaches i never had an
issue with a coach telling me that ed
hockley didn't communicate they might
have said
he's you know asked about his tailor and
if his tailor needed glasses because of
the you know the way the shirt was was
cut but but ed was great from a
communication standpoint and he really
did a nice job in that area well nobody
cares about communicating his legacy is
the guns and you know that dean
seeing that at all levels now the
college officials
have the head cut going
i think there should be testing i'm just
saying that uh
you know the no accusations but just the
eye test here dean see some guys a
little bit jacked up here uh hey thanks
for joining us on short notice great to
talk to you again bud you got it thank
you that's dean blandino fox nfl and
college football rules analyst